read
write
read read if the president were here
one of his greatest
strengths is reading
every time i hit a plateau i want to
make sure that i'm learning from other
people to make sure that i don't go down
if you can think and speak and write you
are absolutely deadly
nothing can get in your way
rise and shine it's espresso time good
morning believe nation my name is alex
and my one word is belong i believe that
the world would be a better place if
more people felt that they belong so to
start off your morning right grab a
coffee and sip on today's message
read and write
over to you michelle obama
[Music]
read
write
read read if the president were here
one of his greatest
strengths is reading
that's one of the reasons why he's a
good communicator why he's such a good
writer he's a voracious reader so we're
trying to get our girls no matter what
to just be
to love reading and to challenge
themselves with what they read not just
read the gossip books but
to
push themselves beyond and do things
that maybe they wouldn't do so i would
encourage you all to to read read read
just keep reading and writing is another
skill it's practice it's practice the
more you write the better you get drafts
our kids are learning the first draft
means nothing you're gonna do seven ten
drafts that's writing it's not failure
it's not
not the teacher not liking you because
it's all marked up and read
when you get to be a good writer you
mark your own stuff in red
and you rewrite and you rewrite and you
rewrite that's what writing is
and if you come out with those skills
and then you're confident and you can
articulate and you can stand up straight
and look anybody in the eye and say this
is who i am it's a pleasure to meet you
that's one of the things we try to do
with our mentoring program with young
girls my message to them is if you can
walk into the white house
and meet the first lady and say my name
is how are you and look me in the eye
then there's nothing you can't do that's
why it's important if you guys walked
here
are sitting here in front of all these
people
standing tall asking questions using
your voice
you have to practice that
these arenas just show up again and
again and then you just get used to it
the nerves go away and you start
relaxing into your own abilities
but it's practice
i love michelle obama's message
as an instructor i am continually trying
to get better as a dancer as a
motivational speaker as a storyteller as
a leader
every time i hit a plateau i want to
make sure that i'm learning from other
people to make sure that i don't go down
because here's the thing once you
achieve a goal you want to push yourself
further into it because if you don't you
start to take yourself for granted if
you're in a relationship with someone
start to take them for granted if you're
not growing you're dying you need to
challenge yourself the one point that i
would add to michelle obama is you don't
just consume your knowledge through
reading and you don't grow just through
writing you can do it through videos you
can do it through audio tapes every
morning i wake up i'm watching someone
inspirational do something amazing or
say something amazing i will watch
michelle obama i watch barack obama i
watch mel robbins and i watch tony
robbins that's a lot of obamas and
robinsons the point is you can grow
through different avenues your
information can be consumed differently
but what's important is that you're
continuously growing because
if you're not growing you're dying now i
have a special bonus clip for you but
before that the question of the day is
what's one area of your life you're
coasting in i'd love to hear from you
please leave it in the comments below
thank you so much for watching we
believe in you and we hope you continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is stay tuned for the bonus
clip and we'll see you tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso thank you
so much for watching another episode of
coffee scents with alex
nailed it
i need to grow my shadow
[Music]
the best thing you can do is teach
people to write because there's no
difference between that and thinking and
one of the things that just blows me
away about universities is that
no one ever tells students why they
should write something it's like well
you have to do this assignment
well why are you writing well you need
the grade it's like no
you need to learn to think
because thinking makes you act
effectively in the world thinking makes
you win the battles you undertake and
those could be battles for good things
if you can think and speak and write you
are absolutely
deadly
nothing can get in your way
so that's why you learn to write it's
like
when i can't believe that people aren't
just told that it's it's it's like
it's the most powerful weapon you can
possibly provide someone with and i mean
i know lots of people who've been
staggeringly successful and watched them
throughout my life i mean those people
you don't want to have an argument with
them they'll just slash you into pieces
and not in a malevolent way it's like if
you're going to make your point and
they're going to make their point you
better have your points
organized because otherwise you're going
to look
like and be an absolute idiot you are
not going to get anywhere
and if you can formulate your arguments
coherently and make a presentation if
you can speak to people if you can lay
out a proposal god people give you money
they give you opportunities you have
influence
books obviously are very important i
read a lot i try to read like two or
three books a week um
and i for me what i mean i realized very
early on and it's a little bit clearer
for me because i work in book publishing
and i'm a writer but like i consider
reading to be like part of my job so
like and that was actually somewhat
weird when i was working full-time in
american apparel it's like i would want
to sit there and like read a book but
you i can't do that at an office you
know
but so now i now i work from home so i
can sort of do i can arrange my day in a
way that like appearances matter a
little bit less but i think
you know
reading like what i what i say is like
okay look um chances are whatever
problem you're going through right now
someone else went through before you
and they probably wrote it down and so
like books are the way that we
we access that knowledge and if you're
not availing yourself to it you're going
to learn a lot of things the hard way
when you don't necessarily need to so i
consider like reading to be like part of
my job and part of what's accelerated
what i've been able to accomplish um and
i just so it's like when people are like
oh how do you have time how do you have
so much time to read it's like well
how do you have time to sleep and how do
you have time to eat and go to work like
that's just what you do
um it's not like this extra luxury that
i squeeze in when i'm
on vacation
got it that was going to be one of my
questions how do you have that time to
read so there's no secret and like i
don't read fast like i think a lot of
people think that people who read a lot
must be like
speed readers and so they focus on that
it's like no people who read a lot just
spend a lot of time reading because it's
important to them and that's sort of the
distinction that i made
you need to read at least 20 minutes
every day
now i spend about two hours a day or
more
but you got to understand this is my
business this is my life this is my
profession i got to do it fortunately i
just absolutely love to do it but 20
minutes a day will make a dramatic
difference now obviously i'm talking
about reading something good
powerful positive biographies
autobiographies self-help books
motivational books books about your
business your profession the industry of
which you are a part books about human
nature how to deal with people if you
are an average reader
that's 220 words a minute if you will
just read 20 minutes a day
at the end of the year you will have
read 20
200 page books
that is 18
more
than the average american reads in a
year's
time
that will give you a colossal advantage
in whatever it is that you're doing
so let me give you the one word secret
to happiness one word this is all you
need to be happy the most important word
ever if you had to think of
one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you up or that would be kind of
like a little beacon
hey believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
tony robbins gary vaynerchuk oprah
winfrey william and howard chiltz i have
a very special secret video for you
check the description for details